what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here I'm John so we a shot our
non-spoiler review for Deadpool on to
our spoiler review this movie definitely
has things that are spoiler worthy right
and it's awesome let's just hop right
into it we're gonna go and order don't
worry we will talk about the end credits
scene we are gonna save that for last
okay but their end credits of this yeah
we'll have credits planes going between
so the first thing to talk about that I
thought establishes the tone of this
film very well one thing I say in the
non-spoiler review is that this film
does a great job at balancing being a
darker film yet a funnier film at the
same time and I think a lot of that has
to do with the setup that leads you into
the opening credits early on in the film
Vanessa
dies because people come attacking wait
Wilson she gets shot and Deadpool
manages to kill everybody and it's very
dark it's very heavy especially cuz the
first movie all hinges off of him trying
to get Vanessa back see that's a great
core cuz it causes him to actually care
about something and the movie does get
like dark in that first yawning moment
and they called back in a clever way to
the first film with that whole wrap
around about like I bet you're wondering
well I'm about to blow myself up I mean
they gather like Logan jabs and whatever
we're not gonna go over every reference
we're not gonna go over every joke so
when she dies it hit me in that moment
going is this gonna be like a really
dark least you'd be able to do this like
I was really questioning it and then it
goes into its opening credits with it's
Celine Dion actually uses it they do
this like Bond opening sequence they
make fun of like a Bond opening and a
lot of the dummy titles it's funny title
sequence because right when Vanessa died
my girlfriend said like that annoying
yeah thing so when they go into their
credits the one of the first things is
the credits are saying like the [ __ ]
killed her off like they're
acknowledging what people in the
audience are peeping
right then in there I was like oh my god
that is so smart we did a reaction to
the Celine Dion Ashley's music video it
got blocked worldwide on YouTube the
video got like a 90% like ratio but all
the comments were like how are you
laughing at this this is a serious song
this is know what's missus most videos
making fun of those music videos for
movies that have these super serious
song yeah inter spliced with footage
from the MV but it's really heavy and
there's lots of gravitas like where's
this gonna show up in the actual film
it's not what you'd expect from a
Deadpool movie but that's what makes it
funny is that it's a great song yeah it
just works in this weird way and like
hats off to Celine Dion yeah showing up
for that that opening credits really
helped establish its tone of going back
from a dark moment to a really funny
moment and finding humor within that
dark moment thinking about the song like
if you dissect the lyrics like it even
relates to what happens in the movie
yeah definitely yeah this film goes in
and out of being dark and really funny
and I think the transition of Vanessa's
death and then making humor out of
Vanessa's death in the opening credits
shows that this films gonna do a good
job at being funny even in scenes where
you're not expecting jokes being
resonant yeah to serious with Vanessa's
death I thought that was a really smart
way to arc him into being a hero I
thought it was brilliantly done so one
thing Wade Wilson seems to truly care
about that anchors him as an emotional
character because even when I was
watching the trailers I was like what
does he want to protect this kid this
doesn't seem like dead yeah what was so
fascinating to me about this movie is
this whole movie is him grieving and you
feel that even in the fourth wall
breaking even in the meta humor even
when he's donning the suit and going out
on missions and cracking all the funny
jokes and [ __ ] unlike the first dead
pool when he is in costume you can still
feel the emotional guy underneath it but
it doesn't strip away the humor in fact
it adds layers I mean you can really
feel there are a couple moments in this
movie where it's cleared Wade really
wants to die and yeah like when his
cancer comes back when they have the
Colorado stuff like that and he's like
actually getting rough like I bought
those scenes you really believe that
he's just getting sick again and wasting
away Oh totally cuz this whole
motivation in Deadpool 1 is to get back
with Vanessa to win her back and then in
this one it's like he wants to save this
kid because he thinks that's what
Vanessa wants him to do
waiting about a family and this is a
family movie in a way it'll bring him
closer to Vanessa again so the whole
motivation made sense so it was arcing
into being a hero was fun like all that
stuff with him working with the X and
speaking of the x-men that was a
brilliant cameo it's not expect were
they I wonder if they're actually on set
maybe they were filming x-men Dark
Phoenix and the neighbor all their stole
a shot in the a screen yeah that's what
I mean about building upon jokes from
the first one yeah it's like for a
second there he's walking around the
halls and being like why is there never
anybody yeah and then right at the right
time yeah James McAvoy you got Ellie
everybody have computers there isn't
people like that's what I mean about
building upon the first one because they
had that joke in the first movie well
the sooner not being able to afford more
expensive eggs yeah yeah it's a big
house it's funny that I only ever see
two of you it's almost like the studio
couldn't afford another x-man for how
much is going on it for how many tones
they're juggling and yeah how many like
sci-fi element like those interludes
breaking in with Vanessa when it's like
that ethereal heaven yes all these
things that could easily go so wrong but
they make it more cinematic and it gets
dark but when it gets back to humor it
doesn't feel jarring which I appreciate
yeah showing the x-force in the trailer
it was smart because you think like oh
they're saving some finale is all the
exports get together yeah you watch the
movie oh my woman they parachute off and
then they always lose gets hit by a bus
yeah they're going wrong you know that
this keep dying in ridiculous ways and
they did credit Brad Pitt be the
vanishing of banasur in a t-shirt
yeah when Britney Brad Pitt's face shows
up they do credit him annex I wonder if
he really did make a little appearance
just for that I wouldn't put it past me
I wouldn't put a fast rap it he has a
good sense especially with all those
interview the vampire jokes yeah so when
they all start dying I thought it was
hysterical I could see the flip side of
someone being like well this is a bummer
I thought the ex yeah I mean you do want
to see the x-force but they're making an
x-force movie we all know that when you
still get Domino's widows worth it it
not I felt like if they did keep the
x-force it could have stripped away a
lot of the effect of the movie because
then you'll be watching an x-force movie
not a Deadpool movie
I wonder if they originally had more
exports than like in a rewrite decided
you know what might be funny like maybe
it is too much let's kill house yeah you
know just use one because there's still
humor that came from Kahn at the x-force
because Deadpool is constantly saying
aggressive yeah yeah no we're still
badass when they're in the prison you
know they're talking about the guy in
the ice box the main Big Daddy muta yeah
the biggest meanest guy and I had a
feeling it would be juggernaut because I
like what else would it be I heard at
least one whisper that like Oh
juggernaut was spotted on set which I
don't know how that's possible oh well I
had heard that maybe it was gonna be the
real villain was juggernaut but even the
way that they handled that so I thought
was cool I thought the whole reversal
cuz you're led to believe the cable is
the main villain and in a way he is an
antagonist but it's really the kid and
then juggernaut you know they become the
main threat of the film that's why the
joke of Deadpool like in a dark moment
looking at the camera and saying and
some obvious foreshadowing yeah I think
everyone knew that eventually cable and
Deadpool would team up just when you
watch the trailers you know the comics
you're like yeah Deadpool on cable are
gonna team up by the end of this to
fight some ultimate bigger baddie
yeah you just don't know when or how
yeah but it doesn't feel stupid because
Deadpool makes fun of the fact that it's
gonna happen yeah and there's enough
other stuff going on to where you don't
spend your time focusing yeah waiting
for it to happen juggernaut it was cool
to have him back it's not like weird
looking Vinnie Jones body yeah it was a
real CGI thing but it's still an
intimidating and scary look and more
along the lines of the juggernaut from
the comics one thing I really liked
about it they lay out that he is a
brother yeah because I remember watching
the x-men cartoon and that was a big
part of it was that their step brothers
came Marko has a line in there where he
says I keep this helmet on to keep my
brother from reading my mind
I remember next three that's not the
relationship that's not relationship at
all in this movie to establish them like
oh that's cool
maybe they might tighten it no but
juggernaut is defeated they have a shop
where he's way in the background yeah
and he's like being electrocuted but
that's not enough to take down
juggernaut so just ask me a lot while
yeah juggernaut still has to be alive I
think that'd be cool if they brought him
back in I was the only one on my group
that noticed the Stan Lee cameo uh yeah
the point out to me and I never noticed
that [ __ ] like painted mural I'm the
last yeah I'm the last guy to notice
that it's when they're parachuting and I
forget who who they're focused on which
character that are seeing parachuting
but on the very far right side there's a
painting of Stan Lee oh it's gone oh
it's all on the right side of the wall
and also speaking a juggernaut I feel
like some people might not be able to
hear it but it was so funny I especially
heard it when Domino is trying to save
the orphans you hear the operatic choir
music it's so subtle too because at
first I thought it was just choir music
and then I started to actually listen to
it during that yeah you know even this
they're making silly and mow totally one
of the last scenes to is like Deadpool's
dying scene I thought was great cuz that
to me strikes the perfect tone
resembling what this movie is yeah and
the sensibility too cuz I feel like
throughout this movie they know when you
are gonna be thinking about you know
it's not really gonna happen or here's
something that I P predictable and they
always tweak those moments yeah the
death scene we're just drawing it out
and having him like go and then wake
back up and say some more you know and
after a while I started to kind of
forget about the whole like I bet he's
not gonna die and I was just sort of
like that maybe they can do it I thought
the writing of him was better in this
film especially like the Deadpool joke
parts because they felt so within the
context of Wade Wilson I wonder if
that's where Ryan Reynolds writing
credit came from like I wonder if he
specifically did Wade's dialogue for
parts of this I imagine he did because
even when he's saying bye it's weird at
times you're like I'm feeling emotional
during this scene like I'm feeling
emotional but I'm cracking up and yeah
feeling a moat and it's all in this one
scene every time he says like his
goodbyes to someone he gets to say his
heartfelt thing but it doesn't can the
Deadpool humor and he gets to say
something hilarious that's still within
context of what Wade Wilson would say
yeah it's it's weirdly heartfelt and
part of that also comes from the
Darcis of the stakes with the king again
going back to that I thought that was a
really nice choice where you have a very
understandable scenario as to how this
kid is developing into a horrible
villain after having saved him and
everything and truly having that
catharsis just before Deadpool's death
scene you know and and yeah having all
the different x-force moments with that
yeah just kind of brought the movie
together in a really nice way totally to
wrap up with Vanessa and the way he gets
sent back like you know he's gonna come
back but it didn't feel silly or cheesy
or like a deus ex machina you know I
appreciate that cable did the whole coin
thing apparently that coin can stop what
cables bullets but it's like it's
definitely I don't really I could care
less
yeah and I like I didn't go back and
just like I'm gonna reverse everything
with Vanessa I don't do this whole movie
you know yeah yeah it's just that one
crucial moment and I feel like that
probably in the physics was just close
enough to where he could probably
control the time each time I use that I
lose control more another thing I
thought they expanded upon and made it
even funnier you know like the first
movie had that one little bit where
Deadpool is growing arm this when he
does the crow he walks over to cable I
was dying
oh so hilarious they don't skimp on
anything
yeah these movies like we save it save
it for last the end credits scene oh boy
the end credits sequence has got to be
the best post credits I mean you've seen
some funny MCU post credits scene like
Captain America showing up or whatever
this one tops any of those I mean like
it's hard to top Sam Jackson talking
about the Avengers something so much
more special it just seems like they
didn't skimp on anything they didn't go
let's save something first
later like let's just throw it all at
this movie let's just go for broke it
almost remind me of 22 Jump Street the
way they end with all the effort see I
just watching him go through time having
him kill old Deadpool like one of the
most gratifying
zany things that was hysterical because
they make a joke about it in the first
step oh yeah that for him to go back to
the actual footage of x-men for
Wolverine and is to shoot him I just
fixing the timeline and he starts
popping a bunch of boats and if you
learn more
yeah oh yeah and even the Green Lantern
oh they make jokes about the timeline in
the first Deadpool movie and people
always make fun of the x-men timeline
being like really weird and confusing
and even though it's done for a post
credit scene humorous moment in a weird
way it kind of fixes it they never
actually acknowledge anything about how
Wade Wilson was around during the
Vietnam War and all these things it's
just like special forces time a couple
of times yeah yeah if he wasn't made
clear that they are completely ignoring
everything about Wade Wilson and whole
that's yeah this makes it very clear
like don't worry about this movie
doesn't care and then even the Green
Lantern bit talking about like this
don't make the suit green they expand
upon that with this post-credit scene so
freaking funny yeah it's like another
joke in the same realm but not the same
joke and I appreciate you guys for not
ever being lazy like if there's one
thing you could never accuse either
Deadpool movie of being it is lazy and
especially not this one and I think the
question though that comes that stuff
where he saves Vanessa's life and then
he saves Peter's life in the X for this
Canon was that just a moment to be funny
or did he just reverse it and undo the
whole movie yeah I feel like you could
probably take it either way it's being a
post-credits scene I almost feel like
it's a comic strip after you just read a
graphic novel I mean if they use this as
a means to have Peter come back or to
have Vanessa come back I don't know what
that would do the stakes but for more
I'm sitting now I don't think I would be
super doesn't know I think because it's
Deadpool especially yeah it's like we
know that there's gonna be a certain
amount of rule bending and that's part
of the fun we can enjoy that here
whereas in another movie it might feel
cheaper I also love that like Josh
Brolin's play to comic book characters
that both have time travel abilities he
calls him Thanos to his face yeah yeah
guys
yeah it was cool I mean I didn't really
notice the whole like gay thing disputed
is something normal so I guess that's
it's a good thing
Deadpool - I love this film this is the
first film I've seen all year maybe even
more than any movie last year where I
was just genuinely happy throughout even
the darker moments I was like this movie
just makes me really happy
well these movies like these remind me
of the magic the blockbusters can be
because this feels like the first movie
did feels like a real movie that's doing
its own things you know it fits in with
the crowd but it's also doing some
unique stuff and it's going places a lot
of the other films won't go yeah and
it's playing with its style in ways that
a lot of the other films don't and I
love Deadpool for that especially you
know these feel like real movies in a
totally different way alright guys well
thanks for watching you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell cuz subscribe
buttons don't really work and check us
out on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A s would love to
have you become a picture object today